the Joe Rogan experience I think you
read too many comments so I'm saying I
think you reasonable ask you what do you
think I really said that I think you did
you never catch me reading them no dear
you've mentioned comments before too I
catch them if if they're in the top and
I'm gonna comment the other day and it
said always well that was because my
wife said it to me it was hilarious oh
yeah that was after the video of you and
I were celebrating and there you go I
love this man I'm like I love this man
yeah and someone said I always wondered
what it looked look like if Cameron
Haynes and Joe Rogan had a baby and we
almost found out that was a good one
every once a while you get a Jim yeah
the Internet is filled with funny
[ __ ] people men like there's a lot of
Larry frustrated comedians out there
there is that get express themselves
occasionally in comments yeah because
isn't in like I sometimes answer because
I feel like I'm let off the hook a
little bit cuz it's not like I'm making
a post calling somebody a [ __ ] but I
can say in a comment and it kind of
sneaks through but why do you want to or
just be funny yes you're so busy that's
what I don't understand how do you have
the time the full time job I mean it's
normal that you run a marathon in a day
hmm so how the [ __ ] do you have the time
to be commenting I don't know well well
like waiting out here right now on the
plane I don't know times of boredom I
guess so yeah yeah it's all good it's a
man I know a lot of people that read
their comments you know and smart
pierrick Weinstein was making an
argument that you probably should read
some of them that there's like and you
know he's a genius he was saying like I
don't want to cut off completely from
from feedback so you have to find that
sweet spot between reading some and yeah
and I'm like I feel like other people
read them I'll get them though they'll
come to me yeah yeah now the good ones
people share with you yeah or yeah but I
know some people who go crazy they read
their comments and then they become
obsessed and they read them all day long
then they go and they have these little
Twitter wars people back and forth yeah
and they they just argue all the time
yeah they're sometimes or I mean like I
posted a couple times yesterday and I
don't think I don't think I ready Neto
maybe this morning you know or just so I
was like I don't post and then just like
totally check him yeah every second you
know refresh refresh but but every now
and then is something nice like I saw
this dude that we were talking about in
the last podcast I reached out to him he
lost how much weight did that guy lose
Jamie 200 and side went from like 417
and 190 side I sent him a DM I'm like
I'm saying this guy Dan yeah that's
[ __ ] amazing it is it's amazing right
you do see people because you know like
when you reach okay you're you're gonna
reach millions of people there's gonna
be a few dip shits but there's also
going to be a few like that
or it's just like oh my god this is I
mean how impactful is that that's like
it affects your life ya know yeah
because it's so positive well one of the
things that you do online I think it's
super important is you provide
inspiration you know we were talking
yesterday when I have to code a Meyer on
we were talking about Goggins and Jocko
and you do the same thing it's like you
provide something where people they
could see you working hard and see you
smiling and and getting after it and it
makes people want to do things and when
they know that you're doing these
hundred mile races and all this crazy
[ __ ] that you do they it gives them like
that's just enough of a push to get off
the couch yeah and get going and
sometimes that's all someone needs to
change their whole life you need a day a
good day a good day where you get moving
and you get your legs pumping and you
you know you get huffing and puffing and
you get your heart rate up and you sweat
and then afterwards you feel great and
you go okay tomorrow I'm gonna do it
again yeah and the next thing you know
you got 15 days in a row and the next
thing you know you're down ten pounds
that's right the next thing you know
you're cutting off with the booze and
you're eating good and now you're you're
joining a gym and you're starting to do
chin-ups and [ __ ] and you're getting in
shape and you look way better and you
feel better you make better choices your
life moves smoother it's yeah I mean
it's it builds that momentum and it you
know the journey of a thousand miles
begins with one step and that one step
is one day or maybe the first first step
on your first run but you know I see
that all the time too because I
genuinely enjoy working hard and so I am
smiling
and it's like people say okay enough
enough I mean I've been watching you for
whatever I'm gonna do it yeah and so
it's like I don't know if you beat them
into submission finally but whatever the
case is whatever reach for whatever
reason people get out there they do and
then it starts that journey like like
you said towards a different life
essentially I joke around about it on
stage about accidentally influencing
dudes and I apologize to the girlfriends
but there is a certain amount of
responsibility that you have to assume
when that starts happening when you do
have a positive impact on people you
realize like hey you know this this show
having people like you and Jocko and
Andy stump and all kinds of interesting
fascinating people on directly
influences people's lives for the better
and changes the way they view things for
the better
gives them a positive outlook and it
also gives them an opportunity to hear
from people the way people think that
maybe they would never get to meet these
people in real life right they would
never get to know these people but they
feel like they know you have em or who
you know that's the one thing I love
about Jocko too is you know just the
shot of his watch every day I mean you
know he's up at 4:30 and he's getting it
done you know
no excuses no none yeah and he's done
and that's I think that accountability
is probably accountability for him but
also it's like the people know okay hey
this is what we need to expect of
ourselves yeah someone a guy said I
don't like following Jocko cos all it
does is take pictures of his watch I'm
like you're missing the point
and yeah that's a new picture yeah it's
a new picture every goddamn day of a new
day with his [ __ ] watch getting up
and getting after it then afterwards a
puddle of sweat in the ground yeah he's
doing it every day yeah yeah and that's
impressive for you it's a it's like and
that was I'd never met him until our our
elk on Utah and man people ask hey so
how is Jocko and I'm like exactly like
wait I mean how what he says and how he
portrays himself that's how it is that's
how he is
he's like you know they had that day
they were expecting a long day of blood
trailing or just covering miles in the
mountains and he's like he couldn't wait
yeah I was looking forward to it
couldn't wait three plates of meatloaf
he did he carved load I mean he's like
hey I'm gonna need these but ya big ol
their own plates of food but he said and
I remember this specifically he said
what sucks is when it doesn't suck mmm
he wants the challenge yeah if something
without a challenge is like what's a
point
yeah he's turned his mind into this like
challenge seeking missile yeah yeah
[Applause]